a lot of people look at finished
products they look at LeBron tonight
they look at Cody today they look at
Beyonce today Beyonce's a good play her
family wanted thought that she would be
a star there would be stars so there's a
lot of film of them on Star Search or
the old video canvas if that was work
when she was a young teenager like maybe
even before she was a teenager she's
learning dance moves like you know now
people see like we'll listen to a song
where she has a lot of bravado and I go
it's a lot easier to to do it you know
to be somebody who's got confidence or
own or is looking for something that may
seem you know disproportionate because
they know the 40 years they put into 20
years they put in the work if I'm
sitting on a couch and I'm like oh that
athlete thanks for so fancy I wasn't
there for the last 150 years that they
woke up at 5 o'clock in the morning to
get them to this moment and that's cut
probably how I feel which is like I get
that like everybody should almost
specially the way I communicate and how
competitive I am almost everybody should
be like who do you think you are but I
also know why I feel like I can do that
because I only give advice I take for
myself I lack any hypocrisy I'm telling
you things that I do for myself I come
here to be patient I'm patient you're
just catching me at 40 catch me at 22
when I'm bagging ice touch me at 25
years old when I'm already got stuff
going on and I'm carrying
offices pretty easy for me to tell you
like be patient
you know like for anybody you know like
because when I was 20 sending this old
already built a big business and like I
already had a real success and comes to
get a lot of money off the table I on
December 9 Wood County your box for you
know three boxes of beer to your car and
said thank you for shopping at the store
and make it look like nothing was going
together nothing is baloney